if you've already finished the Dead
Space remake I highly recommend
returning to the bowels of the ishimura
and trying out new game plus I am a big
fan of these modes but dead space does
it particularly well while most games
just let you replay the game EA Motif
has added some meaningful gameplay
changes and story additions to the new
game plus playthrough so here's why you
should relive the horror a second time
oh and this is spoiler free if you
haven't picked up dead space yet or you
haven't finished it there will be zero
spoilers that said I will be showing
Isaac's fully upgraded rig
foreign
like most New Game Plus modes Dead Space
lets you take all your upgrades weapons
items and cash into a new save once
you've made it to the first in-game shop
you can access your storage and use any
weapon you'd like and they'll come with
all your upgrades however like any good
New Game Plus mode you can't unlock
every upgrade in just one playthrough
when I finish Dead Space the only weapon
I had fully kitted out was my plasma
cutter this means that if you want to
see the full potential of Isaac's
Arsenal it's in your best interest to
revisit the ishimora not only that but
the final suit upgrade is only available
in New Game Plus it changes the entire
look of Isaac's rig though so keep that
in mind before you drop 99 000 credits
on it
foreign
if you've completed the quest to get a
master security card you can open all
master security locks from the outset
this means you should have no trouble
collecting the rest of the upgrades if
you haven't already
I'm of the opinion that survival horror
is at its best when it's difficult and
now that you have an improved suit and a
complete Arsenal I recommend cranking up
the difficulty to hard enemies hit
harder and your weapons won't deal as
much damage as they would normally
however if you play smart and conserve
ammo you should be fine I also recommend
only bringing weapons you like with you
that way enemies will only drop ammo for
the weapons you prefer if you've already
finished the game on hard then you
should have unlocked impossible mode
fair warning this mode is not for the
faint of heart it's permadeath so if you
die it's game over I've yet to try out
in possible mode however if you do
manage to complete it you'll unlock a
secret weapon and a new rig
foreign
trophies and achievements aren't for
everyone I get that but most of dead
space's achievements are fairly easy to
get on a second playthrough in fact you
might be able to clear all of them out
on a second run some even offer unique
challenges one in particular tasks you
to complete the game only using the
plasma cutter that's the one I'm
currently gunning for and it's why I'm
only using the plasma cutter in this
footage if I've already convinced you to
replay Dead Space then I highly
recommend trying this challenge as well
it's a fun way to play that demands
precision and creativity there have been
more than a few instances where I've run
out of ammo entirely and needed to
cleverly use stasis and Kinesis to get
myself out of trouble now if you listen
carefully I said if most achievements
are easy to get there is one called
Untouchable that requires you to beat
the game on the impossible difficulty
keep in mind that if you want to get all
of Dead Space achievements into
playthroughs you'll need to play on hard
for your first run that is the only way
you can unlock the impossible difficulty
foreign
there is a lot to love about the Dead
Space remake but one of the more
interesting features is the intensity
director yes I know that sounds like
marketing mumbo-jumbo but it is a thing
and it helps keep the experience fresh
on subsequent playthroughs according to
Senior Systems designer Dan Kim the
intensity director is a Content
organization spawning and placing
control system basically this allows the
game to tweak a number of different
variables from room to room to keep you
on your toes
okay
enemy spawns lighting and audio effects
could change depending on a wide variety
of factors according to Kim there are
1200 unique events that are possible
thanks to this system while you probably
didn't notice this on your first
playthrough I definitely didn't this
system becomes more apparent on a second
run arguably one of the biggest reasons
to replay Dead Space is for the secret
ending that's right if you complete Dead
Space on New Game Plus collect all 12
marker fragments and place them in the
right spot there is an alternate ending
I won't be spoiling it here but if
you're into the story in lore of Dead
Space it might be worth that second
playthrough of course you can always
just look it up on YouTube if you don't
have the time
foreign
not enough games have a new game plus
mode and the ones that do don't always
get it right thankfully Dead Space is
one of the few that Nails it I highly
recommend giving it a shot once you've
finished your first playthrough for more
on Dead Space stay tuned to GameSpot